vous aimez bien Michel Sardou
ma soeur adore
est avec nous on va parler de Michel
Sardou
vous connaissez toutes les histoires
Fabien effectivement vous êtes là dans
la chanson française ça vient vous
connaissez tous la dernière fois vous
êtes venu avec une paire de chaussures
de Michael Jackson en fait ils ont été
vendues combien de décembre
dans l'intervalle ils ont vendu un
chapeau déjà des affaires de Jackson se
vendent en Europe maintenant pour faire
une parenthèse parce qu'en fait aux
États-Unis il y a encore une rumeur sur
lui vous savez il y avait des plaignants
qui avait perdu leur procès à l'époque
qui lance les procédures contre l'Ajax
en entreprise et donc en ce moment il a
pas là aux États-Unis il a pas encore
vraiment la plus la côte encore ça va
revenir c'est cyclique en tout cas vous
nous donnerez le prix des chaussures ça
nous intéresse
oui pour qu'on parle de Michel Sardou
pour plus pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
il commence à tourner ce soir
premièrement 33 dates au total et hier
BFM TV lui consacré à un documentaire
mal choisi en tout cas parce que le
commentaire je sais pas qui a écrit ce
commentaire en disant la voix de Michel
Sardou c'est fiole ah
une toute petite période moi j'ai vu
Sardou 28 fois sur scène depuis 1973
vous savez quoi on va en parler on
regarde un extrait et on en parle avec
plaisir
la main levée pour rappeler le salut
nazi le chanteur tout juste 20 ans n'a
pas peur de faire la leçon aux jeunes
hippies ce soutient au Ji aurait presque
pu passer inaperçu si la sortie du
disque n'était pas tombée au pire moment
et je sors les chansons la chanson les
ricains non le jour où la décision a été
prise de d'évacuer les bases américaines
en France évidemment c'était pas le
moment quoi de sortir les ricains je
pouvais pas savoir que ça tombe des pile
le jour où je sortais ma chanson alors
il a il y a un gendarme qui est arrivé à
Europe 1
on fait comprendre gentiment qui valait
mieux ce qui a été formidable d'ailleurs
parce que une chanson interdite c'est un
rêve
général de Gaulle quand même chanson
interdite par le général de Gaulle les
ricains le général de Gaulle avait
interdit la chanson parce qu'il
détestait les Américains de Gaulle donc
c'est la seule chanson qu'il a interdite
voilà c'est quand même incroyable
c'était une plus formidable mais c'est
génial pour lancer un artiste surtout en
1967 de Gaulle décide de tous les bases
américaines qui sont du côté de Limoges
Châteauroux là-bas hop on enlève tout et
on les refait repartir depuis la
Libération c'était installé en France
alors
polémique
voilà depuis le début il a fait des
chansons sur la peine de mort il a fait
des chansons sur l'homosexualité il a
fait des chansons sur le viol alors
voyez
bien sûr
quand tu sers d'où je chante les villes
de solitude en 1973 il dit dans sa
phrase je voudrais violer des femmes etc
belle Balavoine en 78 chante une chanson
dans l'opéra rock de Michel Berger où il
dit nous quand on arrive en ville
simplement et il nous dit voilà nous on
viole dans les femmes dans les parkings
personne s'est soulevé à ce moment-là
c'est la même faut savoir que Michel
Sardou n'est pas l'homme de ses chansons
comme les acteurs les acteurs ne sont
pas les gens qui incarnent sur scène et
je pense qu'on confond un peu tout on
fait un amalgame quand ça nous arrange
contre l'un ou l'autre et puis voilà bon
elle a parlé de le temps béni des
colonies honnêtement il se met dans la
peau d'un mec qui profite du système
vous avez compris l'inverse de ce que
dit la chanson c'est ça qui est terrible
c'est le malentendu Sardou tu crois
craquer le Garrido Alexis Corbière ils
adorent Sardou si Sardou était ce qu'on
dit qu'il était mais quelque chose en
fait il y a des personnes qui arrivent à
détacher l'artiste de certaines de ses
chansons
et je pense qu'après voilà on a des
vérités arrangeantes en fonction de
pas tous
absolue des médias et notamment le
journal comme libération quand il parle
de la France France c'est que on parle
de Coluche pour les Restos du Coeur à la
création des Restos du Coeur le soir de
la création il y a Sardou qui a donné
100000 francs au resto du coeur il le
seul à l'avoir fait c'est lui qui a
poussé qui a subi Goldman tout de suite
qui a poussé Johnny Eddy Mitchell
Véronique Sanson à faire la première
tournée en 85 honnêtement n'a jamais
fait crédit et comme il ne sait pas se
faire aimer des gens dont il a rien à
il l'a jamais dit il l'a jamais
dit
mais oui mais oui je trouve ça
malhonnête pour ne jamais le dire le
fait que ce soit un chanteur clivant moi
je dis toujours que si Maxime Le
Forestier avait chanté le France le
France a une chanson de gauche et si
Sardou avait chanté la montagne de Jean
Ferrat la montagne serait devenue une
chanson de droite voilà puisque c'était
la polémique de cet été aussi à travers
des propos de Juliette Armanet et bien
ce qui est très important de comprendre
c'est que on met les gens dans des cases
et on peut plus en sortir et c'est le
cas de Sardou qui n'est pas l'homme de
ses chansons il a le droit d'interpréter
isabelle a raison de rappeler ce qui est
très important donc c'est ça mais moi la
plus belle anecdote sur sardoune
personne ne parle jamais ah une anecdote
un record ah lequel au monde de vente
non non non non mais là on connaît les
100 millions disques vendus tout ça non
non là c'est un vrai record ça n'existe
pas ça peut-être de choquer ah non mais
il y a plus rien qui me choquerait de
nous c'est-à-dire que en fait Sardou a
été papa de deux enfants à 33 jours
d'intervalle c'est-à-dire la deuxième
fille qu'il a eu avec sa première femme
Françoise est né le 4 décembre 73 et son
premier fils qu'il a eu avec sa compagne
à l'époque Babette il est né le 6
janvier 74 c'est du jamais vu au monde
alors ça existe dans certaines familles
bon à l'époque il y avait pas les
réseaux sociaux
personne n'en a parlé
avec deux femmes différentes il en a
parlé lui il en a parlé moi il m'en
avait parlé des gens en 1980 dans une
interview que j'avais fait de lui pour
un journal pour jeune à l'époque en qui
s'appelait Stéphanie et il avait balancé
le truc etc mais ça n'a pas été repris
plus que ça il y avait pas cette cette
finalité qui en a aujourd'hui sur un mot
une parole voilà et c'est qui Michel
Sardou parce que il arrive encore à
faire parler de lui effectivement avec
la polémique sur le lacs du Connemara
qu'on a entendu d'ailleurs
il avait rien demandé effectivement
Michel Sardou est toujours là est-ce que
c'est la dernière grande icône français
monument il est atypique c'est de Bardot
masculin il en a rien il dit je suis
comme ça j'ai dit des conneries je suis
français je suis râleur mais c'est
surtout moi j'ai fait une semaine en
Irlande avec lui en 88 il y avait
Renault il y avait Pierre Perret il y
avait Chade il y en avait plein on s'est
dit il y a des Dao on s'est dit c'était
une émission de Denison c'est dit il va
faire chier Sardou il avait du chagrin
le deuxième mari de Mirail dark venait
de mourir c'est bon bref il était
vraiment très triste et ben il est
arrivé le seul qui a été qui a chanté
12000 fois les lacs du Connemara pour
les potions du Connemara qui a été
adorable c'est ça donc tous les autres
se sont tirés sont allés faire leurs
petites affaires et lui il a été généré
il y a toujours eu de France en France
il y avait là aujourd'hui on a la France
de Cyril Hanouna de Yann Barthès avant
on avait la France
mais c'est très important on avait on a
eu la France de Guy Lux et Jack Chancel
dans les années 70 il y a toujours eu de
France c'est-à-dire que les deux ont
raison et on tort en même temps c'est à
dire que c'est comme ça on peut pas
plaire à tout le monde encore une fois
de plus
une question quel impact Michel serdou
va-t-il laisser la nouvelle génération
de chanteurs français est-ce qu'il a eu
ce qu'il a une influence particulière
est-ce qu'il y a un successeur à Michel
Sardou ouais c'est chaud ça c'est une
question c'est une vraie question parce
que un successeur probablement il y a
des artistes de talents dans la nouvelle
génération aujourd'hui maintenant c'est
les auteurs compositeurs parce que si
écoutez bien l'oeuvre de Sardou elle est
magistrale c'est des grands grands noms
autour de lui ce soit Barbelivien Claude
Lemelle que ce soit Pierre Delanoë que
ce soit Jacques Revol compositeur qui a
pratiquement composé 80% de son œuvre
c'est à dire qu'il est quand même
habillé sur mesure et pour écrire
relisez les chansons de Sardou vous
allez voir c'est sans la musique c'est
des vrais textes et on sait pourquoi les
chansons traversent le temps encore
aujourd'hui
votre émission
qui consiste à dire qu'on peut séparer
un homme de sa production je pense
qu'elle est de moins en moins évidente
et c'est pour ça que de plus en plus on
se pose la question de est-ce qu'on va
étudier demain Céline au lycée est-ce
que voilà et toutes ces questions là
elle se posent on peut pas faire comme
si elle se posait pas je pense que
effectivement une époque qui était
peut-être les années 60 les années 70 il
y avait même dans les sciences humaines
qui étaient très structuraliste on
séparé les choses bon mais là
aujourd'hui on voit qu'on est encore
avec banane
j'habite en France non Michel Sardou
vous êtes pas fans on vous a dit ça
moi une chanson qui est moins connue
dont il a fait paroles et musique c'est
Verdun ah oui très grande chanson
symphonique on écoute bien en 1979 à mon
avis ils l'ont pas parce que c'est pas
dans les immenses tubes de Michel mais
c'est faux rappeler que c'est un auteur
compositeur brillant et votre chanson
préférée Pascal des années 80 je m'en
lasse pas moyen dessus
c'est exactement ça Michel Sardou donc
qui entame une tournée trois dates à 33
dates et ce soir ça commence et pas ça
dans un voyageur
là franchement c'est loupé bah c'est pas
grave elle s'entraide chercher les
pauvres en train de chercher dans le
documentaire il y avait une phrase
formidable de Didier Barbelivien quand
Sardou lui dit à Barbelivien moi il doit
écrire une chanson forcément il a fait
la chanson rouge un moment donné il dit
tu sais écrire commence pas à m'écrire
des imbécilités ou des conneries parce
que moi après toi tu les écris une fois
moi je les chante 500 fois derrière
exactement et je trouve que c'est un
très grandes phrases du documentaire
deux secondes avec fan des années 80
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis
dans un instant
[Applaudissements]